Trascrizione: Luca Tomasi
Revisore: Simona Donda
Sono emozionato.
Questo è un posto incredibile.
Vorrei dire due parole su quello che è
la stella polare per me in questo momento.
Viviamo in un momento forse di ripresa,
ci stiamo lasciando alle spalle,
speriamo, un periodo veramente tragico.
La mia professione mi ha dato la fortuna
di vedere tutti gli aspetti della vita,
sia quelli più drammatici,
sia quelli più positivi.
Penso che siamo
tutti quanti molto fortunati
e che ci piangiamo sempre troppo addosso
di problemi che ci circondano,
e che poi, se guardati
da un’altra prospettiva,
sono veramente inutili.
Sempre la mia professione mi ha insegnato
a vedere dall’alto le cose
da un punto di vista diverso.
A vedere le solite cose:
noi ci dobbiamo guardare da fuori.
In questo periodo sto facendo dei ritratti
alle persone “comuni mortali,”
normali, non personaggi di spicco,
non politici, non attori, ma persone
che vogliono un ritratto da portare via
in cornice, conservarlo come un oggetto,
di una memoria che in passato c’era,
faceva parte degli affreschi
dei nostri avi
e che nel presente non c’è più.
Siamo circondati da immagini, miliardi,
le perdiamo ineluttabilmente sui social,
su icloud...
sui nostri telefonini.
Tediamo i nostri amici,
diciamo: “Guarda,
guarda questa foto, ti piace?
Guarda bello, guarda come eravamo
la settimana scorsa”,
e noi le guardiamo, costretti,
costretti come quando,
forse nella nostra infanzia, ci ricordiamo
le proiezioni dei nostri nonni, zii,
genitori, la domenica, che facevano
la proiezione delle diapositive
con il proiettore Kodak Carousel,
montavano uno schermo,
ci facevano vedere le loro vacanze
al mare oppure in montagna.
Invece la fotografia è una cosa diversa,
la fotografia è una cosa che contribuisce
all'evoluzione dell'uomo.
Ci fa crescere,
è il mezzo di comunicazione
più portentoso che ci sia perché parla
tutte le lingue del pianeta
e perché è immediata.
Chiaramente, la fotografia
deve trasmettere un’emozione.
Quando lo fa? Lo fa quando è una notizia,
lo fa perché ci urta.
Lo fa perché ci fa vedere
un bambino morto, in riva al mare,
in una spiaggia,
lasciato da un mare impietoso
mentre la sua famiglia
cercava di portarlo in salvo.
Anche il problema delle migrazioni deve
diventare una stella polare per noi,
perché le migrazioni,
che tanto ci attanagliano,
in questo paese bagnato
da tre lati dal mare
e vicino ad altre nazioni dall’altra
parte di un mare relativamente breve,
le abbiamo sempre guardate
come una cosa quasi fastidiosa,
che passa attraverso di noi
perché siamo la porta d’Europa
per i migranti,
tant’è vero che a Lampedusa
abbiamo la porta d’Europa
che si affaccia sul Mediterraneo.
Ma noi dobbiamo pensare
che tante di quelle famiglie
non sono soltanto poveri che scappano
dall’Africa, dal Sud Africa
e dalla povertà più tremenda,
ma sono anche famiglie agiate,
ricchi professionisti che
scappano dalle guerre,
che vengono dalla Siria
per salvarsi la vita,
che rinunciano alla loro vita,
alla loro professione,
per cercare di mettere in salvo
i propri cari.
Questo potrebbe succedere a noi un giorno.
Se noi avessimo una guerra fratricida
nella nostra nazione bellissima,
se fossimo costretti a scappare
prenderemmo un barcone per andare
in Libia, pur di metterci in salvo.
Quindi è un problema collegiale,
che ci deve far riflettere,
come lo è l’inquinamento,
come lo è il nostro futuro
dovuto all’atmosfera.
Pensiamo a queste cose,
prendiamo tutti quanti
un elicottero o un aeroplano
e cerchiamo di andare
da un’altra parte a guardarle.
Non guardiamole soltanto
con la nostra ottica,
perché la nostra ottica
ci porta a un vizio di forma,
che è vista monogamica.
Possiamo renderci conto veramente
che siamo tanto fortunati
con tutti i problemi, ripeto,
come dicevo prima
sia di salute sia economici,
però possiamo raccontarlo,
possiamo viverlo,
possiamo
andare a un bar e prendere un caffè.
Questa normalità quotidiana non è normale.
Io in passato mi sono fatto male,
sono stato fermo sei-sette mesi
e lì mi sono reso conto del privilegio
di poter essere vivo e poterlo raccontare.
Ieri ho alzato gli occhi,
ero in autostrada,
e davanti mi sono trovato un camion,
fermo in mezzo all’autostrada.
Per un attimo ho rischiato
di stamparmici contro.
Come sono uscito da questa
deviazione improvvisa ho capito
che la vita ha dei valori
che noi non siamo in grado di apprezzare
perché nella nostra quotidianità
li diluiamo troppo.
Cominciamo a pensare il contrario,
cominciamo a pensare alla felicità
di essere utili al prossimo
e di poter fare qualcosa
in una società sia con il nostro studio,
sia col progresso scientifico.
La fotografia
ci racconta attraverso i grandi fotografi
della storia--e non parlo di Salgado
di Newton e basta,
ma anche di grandi fotografi di cronaca--
ci ha fatto vedere esempi esasperanti,
esempi impressionanti.
Io ho fotografato
500 persone su un barcone stipate,
stipate una accanto all’altra
perché cercavo di ritrarre
un aspetto delle migrazioni che
non fosse quello drammatico, tragico
dei corpi che galleggiano, dei corpi che
affondano in mezzo al mare,
ma uno sguardo di serenità di 500 persone,
che attraverso un elicottero
visto all’improvviso in mezzo al mare
trovano la loro salvezza.
E questo sguardo di serenità
mi ha dato la possibilità poi, negli anni,
di cercare quelle persone, di cercare
quelle famiglie, andare a trovarle
nella loro nuova vita in Europa.
E ho trovato dentisti, ho trovato
ingegneri, persone veramente degne,
di un coraggio pazzesco
per salvare se stessi e i propri cari.
Prendiamo esempio da queste cose
e cerchiamo di volerci bene.
Questo è il significato
di un’immagine statica che invece porta
un’emozione.
Quando guardate un giornale, una
televisione, una foto,
anche su Facebook oppure su Instagram,
cercate di arrivare dentro quell’immagine,
non soltanto l’estetica che vedete,
ma quello che vuole comunicare.
Qualsiasi fotogiornalista
vuole comunicare qualcosa
Cosa? Vuol raccontare quello a cui
sta assistendo perché qualcun altro
possa rendersi conto in maniera
obiettiva, apolitica.
Grazie.